Speaker 1: All right, let's go through the
list.
The rapidly growing it's almost impossible
to keep up with the growing list of vaccine
requirements and mandates now coming forward
from educational institutions, employers,
states, with regard to state workers.
All happening very quickly in the aftermath
of the Pfizer covid vaccine receiving full
FDA approval, something sort of a watershed
moment that was waited, awaited by many on
both the pro and anti vaccine sides, the anti
back sides, either hoping it wouldn't happen
or saying if it happens, then I will get vaccinated.
Let's see if they do.
And of course, those of us on the pro vaccine
side waiting for what was obviously going
to happen with the hope that it will help
get us out of the pandemic.
Now, we've already talked about the Pentagon
announcing all one point three million U.S.
service members will be required to be vaccinated.
We don't know the exact timeline yet.
Presumably it will be a couple of months,
but the military will be vaccinating all active
duty service members.
We've previously also talked about New York
City Bill de Blasio, the mayor in New York
City, enacting mandates for indoor dining
and a ton of other leisure and entertainment
activities in the state of New York over the
weekend.
And the city of New York, rather, over the
There was a very, very extreme anti vaccine
protest.
Maybe we'll look at some clips of that tomorrow.
It's a little difficult to watch, quite frankly.
The cringe is high and the delusions are even
higher.
But let's look at some of the other requirements
that are now being put in place.
And speaking of New York, the New York City
Public Schools organization has issued a full
covid vaccine mandate for all staff.
You want to work at New York City schools,
public schools?
Do you want to teach at New York City public
schools?
You will have to be vaccinated.
That'll take effect September 27th.
And all education employees will be required
to upload proof of at least the first dose
to an online portal going from New York to
Texas.
Texas Instruments, a for profit company in
Texas, will require all U.S. based employees
to get the covid-19 vaccine.
They are based in Dallas.
It is a it's really a semiconductor company,
although I know Texas Instruments for those
graphing calculators that were so much fun
in high school math, they will be required.
Both employees and contractors will be required
to be vaccinated by October 29th.
Otherwise they will lose their jobs.
Disney has reached a deal with the Service
Trades Council Union to require all of its
unionized employees working at Walt Disney
World in Florida to be fully vaccinated by
October 22nd of twenty twenty one.
Fully vaccinated, presumably meaning both
doses, meaning at the latest they will have
to get that first dose in that in the second
half of September.
Remember that last month Disney mandated all
of its salary and nonunion hourly employees
get vaccinated by the end of September.
And now a deal for all of the union employees
to be vaccinated as well.
Anecdotally in Seattle, there are now more
than one hundred and thirty different bars
and restaurants requiring vaccine proof.
And that list is growing relatively quickly,
expected to be even faster now with full vaccine
approval.
And then we also have a bunch of different
stories out of New Jersey.
New Jersey is going to require covid vaccination
for teachers and for state workers.
The governor there is Phil Murphy, a Democrat.
He announced the mandate during a news conference,
I believe yesterday.
Pre-K through 12th grade teachers and staff
and state employees must be fully vaccinated
by October 18th, or they will have to get
tested once or twice a week.
Now, the testing or vaccine, I'm not really
big on it, but there are places that are doing
it.
It's sort of a softer vaccine requirement
to say if you're not, you will have to be
tested once or twice a week and then for something
completely different coming, just showing
the breadth of places we are seeing these
requirements Navajo Nation has now issued.
A vaccine mandate for tribal workers, this
is happening.
The question now is, what are the resisters
going to do?
Some of them are just going to go and get
vaccinated, without question.
But are there some folks that will actually
quit a job over a vaccine requirement?
Are they more likely to fake their vaccination
results?
Will they?
Are we going to see lawsuits come forward
saying that this is a violation of who knows
what, but just some kind of legal attempt
to resist?
This is going to become a huge issue.
Now, the easiest thing from the standpoint
of just like, do I go and find a fake vaccine
card?
Do I hire a lawyer and file a lawsuit or whatever
the case may be?
The easiest thing continues to be just go
and get vaccinated.
It's even easier to actually get vaccinated
than to fake a vaccine card.
It's legal as opposed to faking a vaccine
card.
And it provides you with some protection,
particularly against serious covid hospitalization
or death.
So it's much more useful than a fake vaccine
card.
One more thought on this former guest on the
show, Radley Balko.
It's been years, but Radley was a guest on
the program, I think more than a decade ago.
He had a funny but relevant tweet where he
said, here's an idea.
Set aside 15 million Fizer vaccines.
Give them a weird new name like Hydroxy Ivor's
think, send them to doctors and veterinarians
and acupuncturists and run a viral marketing
campaign calling hydroxy Ivor's Zinke the
secret covid cure the government doesn't want
you to know about that might actually work.
It's the type of thing that might actually
work.
And quite frankly, if you want to have these
people go and get vaccinated, start claiming
Joe Biden's going to ban the vaccine, these
people will go and get vaccinated the next
day if they believe Joe Biden is going to
ban it, because if Joe Biden supports something,
it must be bad.
And if Joe Biden wants to ban something, it
must be good.
I would actually look into that.
The ethics of it, I don't know, but it certainly
would be effective